hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Leia now this is a game
that was unfinished it was released by
the developer because they said they
couldn't work on it anymore or they
didn't want to work on it anymore and
the point of this build is that
supposedly even what they had was really
good so I want to see it for myself and
if it is good I want to actively
encourage the developer to do something
about it hello Oh dad Mouse know who dad
a lot of sensitive okay leo we had to go
out and pick up a few last-minute things
feel free to head upstairs to your room
sorry the television isn't working this
seems like pretty normal stuff why would
my mom send Lee directly to my room I'm
not on a present sure man that sends you
to be on this son of a [ __ ] is immense
hello Oh dad nice and spooky whoa what
did that um okay I guess that paintings
just gone now hello what about this
abstract art kind of weird set up her
house is this anyway
hello okay bye and man this this mouse
sensitivity is there an option
oh man hang on let me see if there's an
option for this okay I'm back and uh oh
oh god oh god oh god it's so sensitive
okay so there's no way to change it
in-game and I thought I could change it
by changing my cell mouse settings
manually but no it just blasted up to 11
Oh mom you said I could come in okay
maybe there's a key somewhere over here
I just got to be like really really
obscenely dicey something obscenely
gentle with it oh yeah I forgot okay so
what happened to you
whatever oh that's what happened oh okay
ah so I was supposed to get a spook
there and I unintentionally gave myself
a different spook than the swoop I was
supposed to get
oh hello same picture that was outside
and is now fallen hello house that is
creepy and low ceiling
oh is this level will you get here
don't open please why not what why what
why wouldn't I open this is that blood
why it doesn't make any sense
mom is that Layla's birthday is that
today actually one month in that it
doesn't say at November whoa oh I
thought though I thought it was moving
up and down for a second there okay
this whoo okay listen it's weird and
dark and I can't see [ __ ] and my wrist
is being strained trying to control who
okay nevermind hi who's in there [ __ ]
you I'm coming in alrighty then
fine hello hi ah good whew if a tree
falls in the forest and no one is around
to hear it doesn't make it sound well I
don't know why don't you tell me mr.
buddy bear ooh
so dark so dark
hello bathroom ah good ah good yes ah
that looks like a normal shower what is
that hello Oh remember this no not at
all no no golden don't particularly but
I bet there's something standing behind
me oh okay alrighty then yeah I thought
this store closed on me didn't
[ __ ] off hi bye okay alright that was a
good visit oh this opened up oh hello
London Bridge is falling the OHS team
Dyess him okay hi
who's out there someone knocking on the
front door oh I forgot to lock it didn't
I
well that was dumb of me ah I did yes
forgot to close that huh well I pretty
much deserve death at this point okay
well I don't think there's any point to
all these just a bunch of basic stuff
that a kitchen has booze no food a
fridge with probably body parts in it
the TV don't work to test that theory
huh yep
that broken got broken alright alright
time to go up to my room
I fold hello oh jeez
wait what the [ __ ] whoa what the what
what is this
well what Oh down stairs oh I thought it
uh Oh what did I do oh hello hi whoa
okay why am I here what happened what
the [ __ ] happened to me
okay I can't really see [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
off don't do that hey movie slumming
around there huh you there now be
thumbing up on me on the thumb master
almost lumpy back yeah alrighty then
who's over there what are you doing here
teddy bear huh go stuffed teddy bear
maybe that means I need to put it to
Bieber there
Death of a Salesman some have the
courage to live some of the courage to
die I don't know about either of those
options how would I stay safely
in-between not actually do anything with
my life hmm oh oh oh oh why why why why
the bridge builder the builder lifted
his old gray heads good friend in the
path I have commie said there follow
deaf
to me today a youth whose feet must pass
this way this chasm that is Benna as not
to me to be that fair-haired youth may a
pitfall be he too must cross in the
Twilight dim good friend I am building
this bridge for him I don't know what
that means I don't know why you do that
I don't know why you have claw hand and
I don't do that don't do that buddy boo
don't be doing that
don't be following me either Liz
horrified alright moving on moving on
hello hi hello who's all good more down
who would have known that my house was
so good and deep and big I can't see
[ __ ]
even with this flashlight I can't see
[ __ ] am I even moving I am moving Hey
I'd rather not
oh okay well oh okay hello ah house
familiar painting how is you ah good to
see you huh birdies birdies no birdies
probably all birdies dead are you live
no you dead
whoa bird suicide inject Inga India blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah Birds
crashing down go berserk century old
phenomena Birds plummeting to the ground
during this time of year oh oh is this
really better it is that better
you know what I'll take it for ambiance
sake I'll take the bird boy late one
automatic young queen stood by her
window gazing upon this island desert
meadows gleaming in the moonlight
crying mournfully of the bird circled
wow I'm not reading all this okay that
was a lot there it was a full story if
you don't know about the story go and
look it up uh you can read it that was a
lot to read I don't know why it was all
in here I don't know why in this room
dedicated to burrow business
Oh
it's December 3rd
you did about a month since all of her
past I still can't help but feel like it
was my fault
I've been so immersed in my studies that
I neglected to attend any of my son's
performances or even spend any time with
them at all I'll have my work become my
life some part of me feels like this is
sort of a catalyst for my son's suicide
my wife has certainly been under a lot
of stress lately as well but it feels
like she was the only one who understood
Oliver I know that Katie is taking this
all quite well and I just hope that Lee
is too young to understand what's
happened oh okay well that was me on the
music stopped okay
is that is that the Sun is that who
we're talking about over here I'm not
hiring sent sure the music oh that must
be why that picture is absolutely
everywhere okay okay thank you
it got eerily quiet after that okay I'm
gonna go now leave I think that's
actually outside I was as spooked by a
noise I sound I heard outside ah yes
good god this is dark Oliver went with
me to the park today I wish you would
play with me more but he only read
Oliver never talks to me and he only
plays with his friends from the theater
I can't wait until I'm older and I can
show him how many friends I have mom
said that Oliver won't come home anymore
mom is crying and I don't see why I hope
I see him soon mom said that Oliver is
in a new home in the sky maybe he's
flying with the birds
Oliver visits me all the time now and he
always plays with me Oliver's the best
brother ever well that's not good am i
lay up oh I thought I saw something oh
maybe I did okay am i Leia or am i
someone I've seen pretty tall for a loop
hi how are you doing oh let me take us
okay goodbye sorry you had another
appointment you had to leave that's fine
it's fine don't worry about me I'm just
a little girl beautiful music great okay
so what the hell is happening here I got
it made it's really intriguing like I am
very very curious about what's going on
in this world and why it's all here
hello hi
hello anybody home please don't say yes
I'd rather not goodie yes I should have
gotten the flash light this candle isn't
doing whoa Leia has been calling more of
them more often than usual just to talk
about random things it was enjoyable at
first but now I can clearly tell she's
upset about something she has been
talking about family a lot saying how
important they are she repeated several
times that Oliver did not want to be
forgotten that really stuck with me
during our conversation today Leia
brought up Oliver multiple times asking
me what he was like and then asking
about his death it was all quite strange
because I don't see how she could still
hold memories of him when I hardly
remember him this is the third day in a
row that Leia is called today Leia told
me that she can still see Oliver she
called and said that Oliver was with her
right then and he wanted to talk to me I
hung up because to be honest she was
freaking me out
later today though she called back and
act as though none of that had ever
happened I think spending a few days
with mom and dad will help her and if it
makes her stop calling me about her dead
brother I'm all for it
Lisbon okay
Lisbon missing for more than a week now
and all the interest shedding Oliver to
suicide as we worried I just don't want
to lose my sister oh okay yeah okay yeah
I'm gonna go get the flashlight again
because it's candle ain't doing jack
dick ah yeah now I can see okay so now
that I think I got everything in here
okay so I think I got everything in all
the rooms so let's go over here
oh that's a deep comforting rumble oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh I
can't see [ __ ] again
is it a maze oh hello what are you Oh
lovely I love it I love to love it and
love the love that I love for it
ah great I'm just hoping that if I
complement I'll buy a birthday cake I
love that love to love that all my love
is pouring out through my love glands
gross Oh Rick alrighty then that's how
you're gonna play it huh that's the kind
of dick that you're gonna be to me yeah
I'll leave that on just to get now to
turn that off that's gonna get annoying
after a while I was gonna do it just to
make a landmark for me so I know where
I've been
oh man I'm gonna get so lost in here oh
jeez oh hello I bright light oh oh hi hi
was that a ghost hand hello looking good
okay goodbye then just gonna go on my
way
all right that assistant Lee over there
I didn't see it so it didn't happen
everybody pretend like that didn't
happen nothing's bad everything's great
what's over here whoa its interpretive
art great love it love to love love and
love love love it oh good I found a way
out good oh great oh good
goody goody gumdrops out of that Oh Oh
No well that's a lot of stairs y-yeah
jeez my hands cramping up trying to
control [ __ ] sorry my that's how
sensitive this thing just slave
movements up in I've been cramping up
trying to keep it steady but when I
freaked out like obviously I can't even
can't even keep a hold of it am I just
gonna be wandering down this staircase
and I'm supposed to assume that nothing
bad is gonna happen to me on the way
down I'm just gonna be living the happy
fun life all the way down to the bottom
oh yeah sure I believe that
okay now that we've gone down the giant
spiral staircase of nothingness why did
we do that what is down here
what a messed up place alrighty then
ooh what's that on the desk there ticket
of some sort
it's like some sort of ticket you can't
click on it though so guess it's nothing
oh it's to the show
ah what a lonely gallery Oh Oh No oh hi
ok this seems okay this seems alright
hello Leah and Oliver okay okay great
oh oh ha [ __ ] where am I going
hi hello hi oh oh good great hello hi be
right with you now we can play together
forever oh oh oh so that's the end
Wow that seemed finished
maybe it wasn't finished but the
developer said that it wasn't finished
but that was still good it wasn't
exactly a satisfying ending but that was
actually really good it had me on the
edge of my seat I was waiting for like
you know in the typical indie or game
where it's just one big closing
jump-scare and then it's gone but it's
kind of neat just to see it like oh my
god no I'm trapped off I'm dead and then
that's it it's over so anyway that was
actually really good I was on the edge
of my seat I mean obviously some
problems and some bugs throughout the
game but it was pretty good the
atmosphere was there I was terrified I
was waiting for something to happen
legitimately I was terrified and I bet
there were probably more jump scares in
the maze in there but I probably did get
to all him so maybe you can so if you
want to play it I'll put a link in the
description below thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye